este problema nos pregunta cuántas onzas
hay en 6 libras muy bien entonces
tenemos 6 libras 6 libras y queremos
convertirlas en onzas a lo mejor no te
sepas la tasa de conversión pero ahorita
te la voy a dar resulta que una libra
tiene 16 onzas entonces si queremos
convertir estas libras en onzas hay que
multiplicar hay que multiplicar por algo
que tenga en el denominador libras
libras y en el numerador onzas onzas y
como te decía una libra una libra es
igual a 16 onzas entonces bueno hasta
ahorita todo tiene sentido verdad las
libras se van a cancelar con las libras
las onzas van a quedar en el numerador y
simplemente hay que multiplicar 6 por 16
y de hecho eso tiene sentido desde el
principio verdad o sea así en cada libra
hay 16 onzas y tenemos 6 libras hay que
multiplicar 6 por 16 bueno vamos a hacer
la cuenta aquí voy a hacer 16
6 x 6 636 y llevamos 3 es por unas 6 y 3
que llevamos 9 96 de esta forma esto nos
queda igual a libras se cancela con
libras 6 por 16 es igual a 96 voy a
poner este color verde entonces esto es
igual a 96 onzas onzas y de esa forma en
6 libras hay 96 onzas